If you were to close your eyes and just listen to the sound,...
...could you identify the movie and where we are in the movie?
Everything is just so iconic.
Even just hearing that, you're like, oh, that's Star Wars.
That's totally Star Wars.
This is The Mandalorian, season two.
So here, we have singularly,..
...these sounds making up the sound of the Razor Crest...
...coming in.
Such a nerd.
It's like what I think is a very hilarious metal wobble sound...
...that I will try and put in everything I ever work on...
...because I think it's incredible.
Here it goes.
We see this metal kind of debris kind of spin off.
It's funny, right?
You'll find that also on the speeder chase on Crait in "The Last Jedi."
When Poe puts his foot through the speeder, you can't unhear it.